hey everybody and welcome to a
very juicy wild ride with stevo
this week we've got a legend of the
music industry who's not just a super
cool
incredibly nice guy but he serves it up
man
the goods on fake jewelry and hip hop
like going broke after spending 40
million
bucks i mean dude this episode is killer
let's get into it you like lobster i do
like laughter
they might be bringing us out some
lobster no way yeah dude we we asked
them if they have shrimp cocktail they
said no we only have lobster
we only have lobsters i've never had
that before i said times four please
absolutely oh y'all [ __ ] it up this is
good are we ready it's all ready
okay it's too high okay all right and
all cameras are recording yes sir
all right perfect here we go this is how
we do it
ladies and gentlemen t-pain
yeah yeah baby let me introduce you to
my co-host scott randolph how you doing
good to see you man good to see you guys
and up at the front of the van the
gorgeous
paul briskey how are you so gorgeous
you're a beautiful man oh thank you very
much absolutely appreciate that
that's what we normally say and you said
it for us ah
i'm here for it man yeah so dude thank
you for doing this well
thank you for having me god like this is
yeah this is legendary for me well thank
you man like this is
it's like dude like i grew up watching
you like this is [ __ ]
insane to me like so i think it is safe
to say that both of us
in our own way have had very uh
influential culturally significant
careers
that was a was it's holy [ __ ] that was
well put well
i think that uh in our own way we have
each
uh very much changed the game for sure
absolutely in our respective industries
yeah absolutely
yeah that makes sense that that makes a
lot of sense i i
mean i got to tell you i respect you for
you know
showing the world uh change and and just
not only putting your body through the
most immense
everything but also changing it for the
better and and
i can't i can't i can't thank you enough
for just showing the world that
all this is possible i mean i appreciate
that a lot you know and um
people sometimes will say man you must
be so proud of yourself for being able
to turn it around
right and my answer to that is i
i'm grateful grateful
[Laughter]
is better than pride on a lot of levels
but let's not make this about me
i get it i gotta ask you first first
question i gotta ask you how much money
are you wearing
um not a lot not a lot la is like my
cheap jewelry place
yeah really la yeah la is like the the
most
robbable place
i can pull out of my repertoire i mean
besides the watch
the watch is the watch is a [ __ ]
is uh is the bezel on that watch after
market or is that
no no this is no this is this is this is
right from it yeah
i mean that's that i i had a rolex at
one time like right right when i was
just
new to being able to afford stuff i was
like oh god i'm getting
rolex and uh and then i put an
aftermarket bezel on it and that that
helps
it helps the aesthetic of it but i think
the uh you know
i i like to put a lot of money on my
watches because
um as robbable as i am uh
the watch is the hardest to get off
right very quickly
so you can snatch a chain you can do all
that [ __ ] i get that
um but if you want to rob me uh
don't rob me out in public because all
that's just gonna be fake uh if i'm in
target and i got jury on that's when you
wanna
that's when you want to really go for it
like if i'm at target at walmart
that's when you really ruin it yeah yeah
that's that's going to be the real
[ __ ] i got on so oh
because less probability all right
and i think i think a lot of people
particularly in the music industry
especially hip hop and r b would not
ever
admit to wearing fake jewelry ever
oh we all haven't we all have it right
everybody has it
everybody has fake jewelry and and it's
the facade of it sometimes fake jury
looks
better wow than the real [ __ ] it's just
it's oh
when you get something that's
manufactured to listen in the [ __ ]
lights of a concert oh my god it's so
much better than the real [ __ ] because
it's just like
it's real this is how it's going to be
you can't get anything else but if it's
if it's manufactured and it's like look
i can make this [ __ ] go
crazy in purple light
it's just this is a whole different kind
of thing it's
built purely for purely for what we're
trying to
uh to create the facade for me yeah and
i think too
like you know having kind of done a
little bit of research i like to
to learn about my guests absolutely
everything that i saw from you
really just uh you know just down to
earth
humility yeah you know absolutely
absolutely and i think that's
you know it's commendable and and a real
indication of that
is admitting with the fake jewelry for
sure so
so the reason you know everybody asked
me why are you so transparent why are
you so vulnerable and stuff like that
and i'm just like
uh if i would have had
the uh the information beforehand
i would have done better in my career i
would have been
bigger i would never would have gone
broke i would have never done anything
but
everybody before me that i had to look
up to they were just like
no this is great once you start rapping
it's going to be
it's just money all the time nothing's
ever going to happen bad
nothing bad's ever going to happen your
family's not going to come after you
nothing's going to happen
it's just just rap and it's just
girls in swimming pools after this
[Laughter]
so about that and and and power to you
for just offering it up
you know a lot a lot a lot of people
wouldn't admit to going broke
after after uh uh after i went through
that whole episode
if i found out if i would have known
that other artists have gone through
this people i'll look up to
if they if they would have just said
that look it's
not all great it's not gonna be
fine this whole time if i would have
known that i would have been
mentally prepared first of all uh i
would have been
i would have been ready i would have i
would have prepared myself
financially i would have put something
aside i would have but
you know from the people that came
before me
even rock stars rappers uh singers
everybody
everybody just like nope this whole
thing is just money
all the time you're good at something
it's just gonna be money
always nobody's ever been like
so this goes away after a while
and nobody is nobody's ever offered that
and i feel like
i have a responsibility and a service
to the people that are coming after me
to like guys remember how great i was
that [ __ ] goes away after a while and
and here's the things that happens
to show you the patterns that
it might be coming it might be coming
here's here's how you know you're
running out of money
here's how when you when you call your
[ __ ] uh uh when you call your
it's your finance team when you call
your finance team
and they're like you may not want to
grab this this
fourth house okay when you start hearing
[ __ ] like
that maybe maybe stop buying jewelry
let's let's not look at an at a bugatti
exactly
exactly let's not look at it i bought my
bugatti
and uh it was fine i was i was fine and
and
he bought it for 2.1 million dollars 2.1
million dollars and then you
very shortly thereafter you found out
that you were actually broke and you
sold it for
all they gave you is 800 000. yeah so it
was like renting a car
for 1.3 million dollars
renting a [ __ ] car and then i was
like hey
since i got this bugatti you know i need
another house i can probably take this
i can probably take this one these
people just moved out of a house
that's literally connected to my house
so you know we can just walk a path and
there's like you
you uh you you don't have any more money
i'm sorry what say it again right i was
like yeah you don't you you
you don't you don't have any more money
and i was like
how how did you let that happen they
were like well
right how did you let that right
all too often it's actually a case where
the the management
the yeah the business manager all the
you know the people are actually
stealing but that wasn't the case
that wasn't the case it was a
combination of it actually though okay
yeah so it was it was you know they were
having fun
with funds but still not
saying when it was running out right
because
they knew if i would have known that i
was running out
i would have stopped making it the
party's over right for everybody
for everyone so don't
don't let him know that he doesn't have
any money because
if he stops trying to make money we're
not gonna
they're like calling you like when are
you going to make another album right
i don't know why i just did
but to be fair to be fair i did see
in an interview you said that it was
your choice
not to even uh have access
to your bank accounts to ever know what
was in there yeah i didn't want to know
personally i think it is a good idea for
one to know
what is in their bank account i also
think it is a good idea for one to know
what is in their underwear i mean if the
bush is out of control down there that
is a bad look for the ladies
and even worse if you got hair in your
nostrils man
that's why manscape saves the day
with the weed whacker which clears out
all of your disgusting nose hairs and
their newest edition the lawnmower
4.0 just rips
through pubic bush man this thing's
killer
and i want you to get one and i want you
to get a killer deal on it
by going to manscape.com
stevo which gives you 20 off your order
plus
free shipping again that's 20 off your
order plus free shipping
and here's another little incentive if
you get one
then maybe you want to bring it down to
carlsbad california on june 17th because
i'm gonna have a big
bush harvesting party that's right i've
been
collecting my bushes for over two years
and it barely fills a sandwich bag
so i'm like screw that man i want to
fill up a huge trash bag
so i'm inviting everybody out follow me
on all my social media platforms for
more information
but the bush shaving fest is going down
on june
17th this month yep that's right it's a
thursday
5 5pm at the beach but make sure you get
your manscaped
lawnmower 4.0 and the weed whacker and
all that
and now let's hear about this bank
account business because
because i didn't want to know because
i was led to believe that this is just
gonna
it's only gonna grow right why would i
what am i gonna do
you know check in on how much more money
i have because these rappers told me
that i'm just gonna make money forever
so nobody's nobody runs out of money
apparently so the
[ __ ] do i need to check in for it's just
gonna keep going up and up
okay [ __ ] crazy so so the peak for
you
would have been 2007 when you were on
three
like bonafide number one hits absolutely
one of which is
diamond platinum yeah 10 million sales
absolutely that's the fluoride a low
song
and uh and so in 2007 you're on top of
the world
i'm talking about and it's never going
to stop yeah like why the [ __ ] would i
check it
right yeah
dude to check yeah he's not waking up
looking at his bfa with his coffee in
the morning like
it just [ __ ] just [ __ ] the
minority report screen in front of me
i'm just like yeah
that's another million
hey but then after 2007
i mean from what you're saying it just
kind of cooled off
right like right so so what so what uh
what
my whole business model at that time was
um
you know it's all going to be downhill
everybody's like it's downhill from here
uh but downhill in an easy way so if
they they
the analogy was if you pedal up the hill
you can coast afterwards right okay you
just stop working
that's so funny in our world of recovery
like we're sober guys
you know they they talk about the work
that you do in recovery yeah
they say you can only coast in one
direction and that's downhill
absolutely the opposite
right now meaning you don't want to
coach yeah so you don't want to go so
you you have to keep working
uh what they what they don't tell you is
that you coast totally fine
you coast um there's another hill
you gotta you gotta keep going and but
uh you know even i was telling my wife
like i didn't i it got so bad i didn't
live with my wife
like for like three years and i was
because i was like if you live with me
i'm not gonna be able to pay attention
to my career
oh and i was like you gotta live in a
different house
everything and it was so crazy it was
how much of that was a smoke screen
for like all of it all of it
right all of it was just like i can't be
held you know what i'm saying it was
like you know you know what i mean it
was just like
there's no there's no way for me to
maintain this lifestyle there's no way
for me to
you know i always tell people the
hardest thing about being number one
is staying number one sure so i was
so upheld with that i was just like
nothing
else can come into my life right now
right and i was already married for
[ __ ] four years and
i was just like you gotta stay in a
different city
and i can't started out different house
and then it had to be a different city
just the whole thing okay
nobody can talk to me don't nobody talk
to me i need to stay number one
nothing can nothing needs to [ __ ] with
me
right now and then turns out it was me
that was [ __ ] with me
forget about just three number one you
were 21.
right yeah oh damn and you were
not it wasn't just three number one hits
you were on [ __ ]
everything i mean yeah you were on every
and absolutely this is like the
auto-tune thing
yeah like you were like the share did it
first and then you made it real
really cool it was a real it was a real
so
yeah it was a real thing by then and
then
auto-tune kind of became the norm
yeah and people started criticizing you
for bringing that to the table
and then as a result of like jay-z
coming out and
attacking you does that have something
to do with why
things cooled off for you i don't i you
know what
um it came to it it was
the craziest coincidence of time like
right before jay-z came out with death
of auto-tune
uh my managers were like dude you're on
a [ __ ] thousand songs we gotta stop
right now we gotta stop nobody's getting
features nobody's doing anything we just
need to
get you out of the media for at least
like some
months and then right after that jay-z
was like
boom that's a bottle tune and we didn't
plan this
but i mean we planned our uh break
so my managers are like dude you need to
disappear for a minute
and right after that you're overexposed
and then right after that jay-z dropped
death of auto-tune
and it looks like a diss track it looks
like a diss track jay-z dropped the
joint and then i disappeared
oh [ __ ]
so it was just like [ __ ] and what year
was that
this was like eight nine yeah
this is like eight nine and then so bro
like
my managers was like dude you gotta just
calm down you're on too much [ __ ] you're
overexposed you gotta stop and i was
like you know what
that makes sense a month later jay-z
drops
death of autotune and it looks like he
made me disappear
right so and then you went after him
i went after him a little bit it was
like i was
i was uh this is one of the recovery
stories
i was just so drunk at a show in vegas
and i was doing um i was doing a daytime
pool party
and uh you know this was right after
death of autotune
and people were in the crowd like jay-z
killed you
like it would you say jay-z shut you
down and i'm like no
you don't understand you know you don't
have time to explain
right you know what i'm saying so it's
just like [ __ ] you
so it was just a whole bunch of [ __ ] and
and
and that came out as t-pain is
attacking jay-z and i'm like no i just i
was doing a show and everybody was like
dynasty [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] it was just like
it was so much [ __ ] man it just
came out as that whole thing and yeah so
then did that inspire
uh or jay-z to come again
no no no no no no i mean the the crazy
thing is what i found out after that was
jay-z was never talking about me in the
first place
so he was he was talking about rappers
doing the [ __ ] like he was talking about
rappers copying me
and he was like kind of low-key
like defending me all right and then i
took it the wrong way and it was
like oh that's [ __ ] embarrassing
[Laughter]
how long after that do you buy the
bugatti and then sell it for 800 grand
and then
oh that was before that oh [ __ ] that was
before that was [ __ ] before that so i
was getting punched while i was down
already
so you're telling me you made 40 million
dollars
blew through 40 million dollars and went
broke like
all in the same it took me i will say
so this is from 2005. in 2006 is when i
made the 400 million dollars
so it took me pretty much
nine years to go through this whole
cycle okay you know what i'm saying so
it was it was it was a [ __ ] but it was
nine years sounds like a long time but
that's fast
right that's really [ __ ] fast
i get it yeah so so what year would it
have been
and by the way this question is because
i'm starting to question ah did he
really go broke
you said that you had to borrow money to
buy your kids burger king
at some time what year would have that
been that was
10 11. okay 2010 2011.
yeah all right and so that was the
toughest of times
now you're talking about like it took me
two years to get all that back
okay oh all that back oh it took me two
years to just like
because because it took me going broke
all the way to be like oh that's where i
[ __ ] up
right and it's just like okay maybe
don't
[ __ ] buy houses in in in homestead
[ __ ] florida
oh that's where all my [ __ ] money
went okay got it
right now we're gonna fix that got it
not gonna do that anymore
we can probably just we can skip all
that okay here we go
let's do that again do it again do-over
so you did it again yeah and what did
you did you think at a point where like
[ __ ] i'm done
i'm never going to be able to be
successful again or jordy you always
know
oh yeah oh millions of times really
yeah but it was my wife my wife was like
dude
you're good just yeah just do it again
you're good
just do it again you're telling me
that i've shown the world that positive
change is possible
all right hey get get get you get you
one of those
get to the wife my wife my wife was like
you sound stupid right you just
come on you know you're talented stop
doing the self-pity [ __ ]
get your ass up do this [ __ ] again we
got kids
obviously don't do anything or dude
that's excellent man yeah
yeah so we're just but we're back on top
man
absolutely we absolutely have we have
different jewelry for different days of
the week
and depending on where we are we got
geographically
we got geographically
son for motivated
beatrice has a target yeah what's that
what's a ticket it's a ticket
a ticket is a million bucks yeah i'll
take it as a million yes is there any
other words like a two million
around your neck i mean we got 500
thousand stack uh a buck
um what's that a a stack is a thousand
a buck is a hundred okay but it could be
a
a buck could be uh what's a band i feel
like a bat a band a band is a thousand
thousand what's ten thousand
ten thousand ten stacks can you yeah can
you combine them like a buck stack would
be like a hundred
thousand well now it's like roman
numerals you know yes
yeah i think that's i think that's
allowed that that can be allowed
you could buck stack a but
okay then let me ask you this what
what's the different number of sales
with gold platinum diamond like what
does that break down
gold is 500 000. platinum's a million
diamond is 10 million
absolutely what's that what's the most
anybody's ever sold like triple
ah michael jackson hcdc what is that
they're uh
probably like 30 million i know 50 did
50. oh [ __ ]
okay 50 did 50. 50 to 50.
that's
[Laughter]
yeah yeah he went crazy um cash money
records like if you combine all their
[ __ ] they're like
50 60 something right and the thing is
about cash money millionaires they
[ __ ] own their own publishing so you
got to multiply it by
50.
[Laughter]
god dammit [ __ ] [ __ ] i know jesus
they couldn't say it because it's like a
22. he couldn't ever blow up
unless he had a record deal for sure but
you couldn't make all the money
unless you're on your own publishing so
like
you know yeah they did both and they did
both
very few people did abs oh very few yeah
master p
oh my god yeah master p did it rich just
out of jail
and then there's [ __ ] went back
and bought their music right
yeah you can go back you can go back and
buy your masters like uh paul mccartney
bought michael jackson's [ __ ]
the opposite how was the opposite
michael jackson
because when they got together oh yeah
yeah they got together to film a song or
record a song together and paul
mccartney says man it's all about owning
their own music
tastes good
it did say say they did my girl the girl
is mine
the girl was fine yeah the girl oh my
god we're actually
uh on the what's today so in a few days
we're actually redoing the seise video
wow
yeah for one of my singles it's gonna
kill her okay i i got
now the whole story about how you just
uh you know you did your own
unsanctioned
on your own time like uh you know you're
a struggling artist with a dream you
re-record a con
song yeah it gets to a con and he calls
you up you hang up on because you don't
believe it's him
and and then a khan hires you right as a
writer not an artist absolutely not
insulting on any level
no no i was trying to get a job at
mcdonald's like i'll take it
right absolutely i'm trying to get a job
at mcdonald's bro i was like dude
anything
that's going to make me more than
mcdonald's right whatever you want
i'll do anything you want he said if you
hire me for what i'm good at
right sure so akon hires you as a writer
and you and you say okay this is great
akon i'm writing for you
and i wrote you this great song it's
called i'm sprung right
and akon calls you a [ __ ] calling a man
a [ __ ]
is not cool but do you know what is
super uncool
dying unexpectedly and leaving your
loved ones who depend on you
totally screwed because you didn't have
life insurance
and if you're sitting there thinking man
i really probably should have life
insurance here exactly
right and you know how you could save 50
or more on life insurance you go to
policy genius.com
why because they make it super easy to
compare quotes
from over 12 different major insurers
making it definite that you're gonna get
a great deal
and we're talking about like 1300 bucks
saved
that'll help you out this summer won't
it help you have a real good time
and sleep very well at night because you
know your loved ones who depend on you
are taken care of yeah so one more time
you go to policy genius.com
where they make everything so simple and
so easy
and compare all those different quotes
to make sure you get the
best one and save 50 or more
policygenius.com yeah now
what's this about calling t-pain a [ __ ]
songs for women [ __ ] yeah
damn dude
didn't recognize you as an artist
initially right then
he hires his writer you'd write a song
for him he says that's a [ __ ] song for
chicks yeah
you say okay cool you go ahead and
record it yourself yeah it becomes a hit
and now you're getting like offers from
every major label
what was it uh it was atlantic offered
you 900 grand uh that was um
interscope interscope atlantic offering
700 yeah yep yeah and then and then acon
turns around he says i'm gonna offer you
20 grand 20 grand but i'm gonna give you
a career
absolutely and you go with acon
absolutely he was the only one offering
long-term benefits but couldn't he given
you a hundred grand in a career
i feel like yes but you know my dad
also needed money at the time and you
know it was just he was the only person
that was assuring me that
it would go further than this one song
and he believed him
absolutely this is like this reminds me
of the [ __ ] movie about
facebook the social network mark
zuckerberg yeah and they're like
they're like by by the way or maybe it's
not that but something like buy their
silicon valley absolutely yeah
silicon valley sell it for this much
money no no i'm gonna hold on to it
because it's got value
yeah yeah no it was it was it was real i
not only
it wasn't just that i believed them
because they said it he was the only one
that said it was the only person that
said it everybody else was like
we'll give you a million dollars we gave
you 900 thousand we give you seven
thousand and that's just for the one
that was just
for the one song everybody everybody was
offering me that [ __ ] but
aekon was like look this song is so good
i know you're going to make
more songs yeah so not only am i going
to give you 20 grand right now
i guarantee you you're going to make
millions more
yeah and it was it was just yeah
right like your first
album that was the one called robert
zarzanga
rapper turned singer yep that's a
[ __ ] reckless title for an album it
was ready to go
because i was because you know in my in
my city of tallahassee florida
everybody was rapping and once i started
and once i started singing
everybody was like in my
in my view in my view i i heard i was
like wait a second his album was called
rapper
turned singer god that's ballsy that's
[ __ ] reckless
right because because because it seems
to me like okay people who are really
in like hardcore into rap yeah you're
alienating them because you're saying
i'm not a rapper i'm a singer
and the people
that you're getting into is always going
to be scrutinized by the people that are
already in it so
you know i was ready for both sides of
it but it was it was uh
the fact that you know in my hometown
there were so many rappers
everybody was rapping right and there
were very
few singers and it was just like i think
i'm gonna go to the other side man and
you know
and i was already in a group and i would
always sing the hook sure
of every song that we would do and stuff
like that so it was um
it was an easy choice and the fact that
singing would
set me apart from everything that
everybody was doing in the city it was
just like
you were producing you were singing you
were rapping yeah
like you were you were writing you're
doing it all i was the i was the
i was the head of the group i mean right
i was the head of the group
in my eyes when i was the younger dad
was the manager my dad was the manager
but i was the youngest and everybody
[ __ ] hated
all that [ __ ] it was just like
why the [ __ ] does your dad have to be
the guy
i don't think any of you guys you you
want your dad to step up
[Laughter]
and i wonder is it really widely known
that your name
t-pain comes from tallahassee pain
everybody knows that
it's not super widely known the thing is
my name was
uh mr torturer wow
terrible name how'd you get that name
i don't know i know i know i had a uh
i had a kawaii key station
it was just like this keyboard that i
used to make my beats on and i
named it mrs torturer
so i guess all in all just
from the events my name had to be mr
torture but um yeah not
a dude i used to rap with uh he he was
like i'm
i'm i'm not calling you that
and he uh he was like tea it's gotta be
tea
steep pain i guess and i was like yeah
that sounds
that sounds good it was like but it's
the t for torturer
and i was like ah maybe not i guess um
it's like tallahassee
tub yes boom tallahassee pain there you
go we did it
piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um now uh
the name the name of that group that you
were in was called nappy heads yep navy
hits yeah then
you leave the group you become a huge
solo artist on your own yeah you start
your own naval
your label is called nappy boy nappy boy
yeah nappy was that a diss to the group
no no it was actually an
and uh yeah it was in the last of the
group uh you know we always used to call
ourselves the nappy boys
um you know because we would get
confused
with that uh
it was another group that we used to get
confused with and we would always
have to say like no we're the nappy boys
like we're
like no we're the other ones like that
was another group that was in
tallahassee it wasn't no it's another
group with nappy in their name okay got
it
so and um it was
pretty close so so we would always have
to say
no we're the nappy boys we're the we're
the ones and uh you know
always in our in our songs we would
always say you know i'm a nappy boy i'm
a nappy boy and everyone everywhere so
uh i just felt like it was an homage to
where i came from
to be like yeah nappy boys that's more
entertainment
when did you start that label um i mean
officially it started the second i left
the group
but you know right now i mean it started
to probably you know
uh you know really officially
like all the way paperwork everything
done
two years ago two years ago wow and
that's why we got all these different
sets of jewelry
absolutely okay
do you still have contact with the group
uh the guys some of them some of them
some of them i mean we had we had some
ups and downs and things that we you
know went through and you know uh
some of them did some crazy [ __ ] to me
and you know some unforgivable [ __ ] but
still it's
you know i'm a forgivable person you
don't seem like a guy who holds a grudge
no no no no no no i
i let it go i i let [ __ ] go really
quickly
yeah you know uh i i you know and even
if i don't
um if you're a good person i just know
not to do business with you anymore
it's not you know it's not a you know if
if you
[ __ ] with me on a friendship level then
cool where's their friends i just
i'm just not going to trust my money
around you like you know what i'm saying
like
that's uh lessons learned yeah we can go
to the park we can [ __ ] we can [ __ ]
around we go to the club i'll just [ __ ]
i'll
pay for your drink what you want but i
know not to [ __ ] sign contracts with
you anymore like
it's i can i can separate things
compartmentalize
absolutely right compartmentalize to the
to the highest level
yeah does like winning a grammy do the
same thing for like a comedian getting
on the netflix it's like once you're on
netflix you're [ __ ] just
super skyrocketed in the stardom like no
no grammy doesn't change your life no
really
no it's just like a
um it's a validation for sure you can
definitely take your prices up for other
[ __ ]
but once you get on netflix like they
pay you
you don't get paid for a grammy yeah
yeah you don't get paid for a grammy
thing to win an oscar they're [ __ ]
yeah this is not like everybody wants
that guy in his movie right
it's it's affirming for sure wow it's an
affirmation
no question and you can you know you can
run around town saying
i want a [ __ ] grammy i'm obviously
going to charge you more now
right but to say it's life-changing no
okay now i gotta ask you this
wait sorry i'm getting the signal that
the lobster is sitting outside
right now do we know what the place is
[Laughter]
got it i gotta ask you this at one point
i was working on music i was trying to
make a
a comedy gangster rap album [ __ ]
so i'm taking you you never knew about
that that was a crazy amount of words
you just said right then it was a
[ __ ] combo
jesus comedy rap album comedy wrap up
yeah i had a track called snitching his
bitching
okay then funny concert wait i made a
wait
i may have known about this yeah i did a
track with cool g
rap oh [ __ ] you know what i did know
about this
holy [ __ ] we made a track called pokes
puss
you were about to make a [ __ ] hour i
got a record deal with the universal
music group
i think i think i know about that he has
a redemption album coming out soon
so now here's the thing all these years
later i'm trying to
i'm trying to make a redemption track i
feel like maybe even a redemption album
i feel like you need to do that we were
just talking to the doc
oh [ __ ] and uh he and i both have
iconically [ __ ] up voices
this is this is this is this is a part
of it yeah
and we've been texting back and forth
about the idea and i'm saying hey man
like
maybe like uh the theme of it
could be like yo man we're two guys who
almost died
we kind of sound like we did
you know like yeah you know one foot in
the grave and the voice all the way in
right yeah there you go you get it and
uh
and so that's crazy i wonder if uh
you know if am i talking to the right
guy to make some music yeah what the
[ __ ]
did what we're talking a bunch of people
i feel like this was
this is already ready to go yeah what
the [ __ ] yeah
yeah all right so if i come up with like
a number of different sort of concepts
for records i don't think you have to i
think i'm just going to send you a bunch
of [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah let's work for you i feel
like
so now here's where i'm really getting
interested
one foot in the grave is like just
already a
dope [ __ ] goddess one foot in the
grave all right i think that's good
that's what they say one foot one foot
in the grave the other on a banana peel
who says that i've never heard that
before it's amazing
that's [ __ ] sweet yeah see this is
all this is all a good
song okay now uh yeah i made a track
with be real
oh [ __ ] yeah i made a track with b
wheels called it if i die
today if i die today oh and his [ __ ]
verse on there was so far
i'm just too embarrassed of what i did
on the on the song to do anything with
it but like
that's gotta happen obviously yeah yeah
so so um
yeah let's let's [ __ ] with that now from
a business sense
if uh you know nowadays you don't have
to have
uh a record deal with a big label thing
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
22 of like you can't blow up with that
record label
right yeah so if if we independently
make a track okay then uh how do we
collect on the publishing how do we get
the nielsen scans
we get everything we get everything we
uh keep track of what we're doing
right yeah we can do that we can do that
on uh on a nappy boy
everyone entertainment absolutely yeah
we have we have the the tracking we have
everything so we we
uh we have different apps that we use uh
we've developed our own app
that you know we we keep track of
literally everything out now
and what um you know uh
the homie sauce walker has done
uh he's made uh credit cards for his
artists
so any streaming that happens for his
artist it goes the the proceeds go
directly to the credit card that the
artist has
oh it's gotten that [ __ ] crazy
it's gotten that crazy so any artist on
his label
whenever they whenever their streams
generate money it goes directly
to their credit cards that he had when
you see a credit card you mean like a
bank account
no it's a literal physical card that
they have in their way oh
yeah like a prepaid credit card and
there's the credit on it
straight it goes straight to that card
yeah so it's a bank account
connected to that card and every time a
stream makes money even if it's a
[ __ ] two cents
it goes straight to that [ __ ] car
they haven't everybody's coming off as
spotify that's coming
off of anything yeah called title yeah
and
then presumably like uh apple apple
music yep app all that [ __ ] pandora
everything there's any stream yeah it's
a lot what the [ __ ] is going on these
days right
they were saying i mean clearly the
music industry has changed more than any
other industry yeah for sure
but uh but it's not like there's no
music in it it's not like there's no
money in it
there's a hundred times more money now
there's a hundred times more money
yeah okay how how so uh
because it's easy music is more
accessible
when you think about when you think
about even in in
in the film industry you know it's a
hundred times
more exciting everybody's making money
it's it's a hundred times
more money a hundred times more
accessible because you know think about
uh let's just say early even early 2000s
you had to go buy cds right yeah and
then you get a lot of
people taking a slice out of the pie
because you got the
the you've got manufacturer retailers
absolutely
you've cut out every middleman you
literally make a song on your computer
and
upload the song from that same computer
and there's nobody in between that
yeah and now there's so what do i need
nappy boy for
you don't yeah we're not
very good that's why he's going to use
you because you're just so transparent
the only thing you would need nappy boy
for is if you're lazy [ __ ]
okay yeah i'm not lazy yeah so i mean
but no i mean
it literally it it is literally that
easy but you know there there are
tutorials out there
to do these things and you know people
come to nappy boy because
it literally gets a little overwhelming
because there's so much to
do now there's there's a there's a
simple way to upload your music
real quick to apple music i get that but
there's also 14 other joints that you
didn't think about
right now that's what you need nappy
wood entertainment for and that's what
we're gonna do
like as far as we're gonna take care of
every single [ __ ]
one every possible way that when we say
this song is out now on
all streaming platforms it's all of them
it's not just the important ones that we
hear about all the time it's the ones
that you just found out about yesterday
this guy that just made one from his
[ __ ] room the other day
like we we take care of all of that and
that's the
that's the strenuous [ __ ] of it and i
even hate doing it
i even hate doing it i hate uploading my
music i got [ __ ] four people that
does that [ __ ] for me right
you know what i'm saying i'm not sitting
in my [ __ ] bedroom after i make a
song like yo upload this [ __ ]
let me ask you this is uh is being with
with nappy boy or any like music label
for that matter
kind of like having a podcast that's
with a podcast
network compared to you could do a
podcast on your own yeah for sure
absolutely absolutely but the podcast
network
might be able to plug you in with
selling the sponsored ads better it
might be able to promote
the the network entertainment is
resources
it's resources and it's probably
promotion
it's affiliation it's the name you're
gonna get me to get more uh
uh features yeah the name is established
already
you know what i'm saying it's already
when you throw when you throw out
t-pain as opposed to just like a guy
like
we got like a guy that just
he i guess he has good conversations
like that's like no i'm not doing it
so do you do any music with nappy boy
that's not like
hip-hop r b oh for sure or you do oh we
have a ton of [ __ ] that's not hip-hop
okay now so if my man paul briskey has
some music that he would like you to
hear
is that like uh yeah let me hear it oh
yeah i love money
i love that [ __ ] this pop paws got some
great [ __ ] music man
your money comes from everywhere i would
love to yeah absolutely yeah
we were hanging out with post malone and
paul said hey you know
i would be remiss if i didn't play
something you're gonna do some [ __ ] and
post said let me hear it and post love
that [ __ ]
beautiful yeah have you seen primalone
[Applause]
yeah i'll airdrop you some stuff uh
after this i'm fine yeah i'm [ __ ]
with that
especially one more lobster yeah yeah
let me ask you something so so you make
the bartender song
was it to a specific bartender girl yeah
did you ever go back to him
like i just made you the sickest song of
all time
not at all i'm not that song at a
[ __ ] hedonism
really in jamaica and everybody was ass
naked
uh i had to borrow the xlr cable from a
[ __ ] dj
at the at the hedonism i i have to i
have the picture of
my setup it was just a laptop a [ __ ]
uh
beach by dre speaker and [ __ ] like that
and it was uh
you know i only liked the bartender
because
everything was free so yeah it was like
an all-inclusive thing so i was just
like [ __ ] drinking and drinking and
drinking drinking
and uh yeah a funny thing about that
song man
uh right after i made that song i saw i
went out
and saw a bunch of uh
uh police tape around the the resort
and uh i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on
and uh i just went to the bar again
and saw this guy oh white guy he was
just
like in his [ __ ] 70s
and uh
i i was just i offered him a drink i was
like man let's let's have some fun
you know just you know not trolling or
[ __ ] with people but uh
his name was bob [ __ ] around bob
and he was like uh that police tape back
there
is uh because my wife just died in the
hotel
and um he said i was getting ready to
i was at the bar taking my last drink
and
he was gonna kill himself he was gonna
kill himself and he was like the
the way you came up here and showed me
love and
just had fun with me you and your friend
and i'd still talk to them till this day
that was like damn no let me buy you a
drink
yeah yeah i mean
but it was like it was like a it was
like i think i mean obviously it was
free but it was just like dude
like he was just looking down i was like
dude what are you doing get up get up
wow did some [ __ ] he was like i was here
taking my last drink and
i mean i've been talking to i've been
talking to him ever since
oh my god wow yeah man that's beautiful
yeah
it was that that was crazy and that that
came from barnes and that
the song bartender was made during that
and then all this [ __ ] happened at the
end yeah so
you know bob i love you brother i love
you
i love you bob that's a beautiful story
man yeah man that is a great story
man you said i love money i do it
so what what other stuff do you have
your hands in i mean is it all
music i know it's amazing it's mostly
music
obviously nfts you got to do that now
music on nft are you doing art i have an
album that never came out i have like a
detail you know how um
dr dre has this detox album yeah i have
one of those
it's called stoicville the phoenix so
why didn't it come out
my label just didn't want to drop it at
all they didn't think it was good
so but i've been showing it online for
years and
my fans are like what the [ __ ] like why
hasn't it why haven't this come out and
[ __ ] like that
and it's just time for it to drop but
i want to make money off of it so that's
pretty cool so it's already out there
it's not out there it's not fully out
there
it's like out there in stream quality
like it's there's no full quality
version of it so far so i think that's
what they're gonna make some money off
of that
yeah what about like physical merch
physical merch
um it's that's weird
to me merge is weird to me oh yeah yeah
i don't know what it is
okay fake jewelry dude those are things
yeah just like
do how much do you like wearing somebody
else's clothes
[Laughter]
what about wearing somebody else's fake
jewelry yeah
okay that's that's kind of cool for a
night
for a night one of my friends going to
my house like bro i need a chain real
quick boom here you go
stuff at me it's that fast it doesn't
doesn't take anything else i need to
impress a [ __ ]
boom there you go yeah i i like to
ask you know almost all of our podcast
guests
like like what their different revenue
streams are like where they're getting
their money yeah you know and we
essentially just try to download
information for us to sharpen our game
mine is mostly video games i'm not gonna
lie to you you're
i'm making more money off of video games
than i've made in the last
four years no just playing them
you're making money playing videos
playing video games so that's
playing them on twitch yeah so from your
twitch stream
you're getting more revenue than from
music yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah what how
is that possible i don't know it's it's
just i mean
because it's because it's authentic
it's just because it's organic are you
good at video games oh no
and i think that what that's what makes
it better
i mean there there are definitely good
uh good players out there that make a
ton of money but i think the
entertainment that comes from
somebody like me being trashed at it
mm-hmm i think that's just more valuable
yeah and it's more entertaining i
set up a twitch yeah like i don't get it
you know
you know what you know what it's like
you know what it's like it's like
watching
football okay because everybody's like
we're just watching people play video
games
like you just watching people play
football
you're not you're not on the field like
you're watching football players play
football you're not playing
where does the money come from is it the
other users people literally
pay you they pay you to like shout them
out like uh you don't even have to
you don't even have to they're just
kidding yeah how are you gonna
concentrate on the game if you're like
thanks
andrew you do that while you're playing
but
uh there's these things called uh off
stream subs
and people literally pay five dollars a
month
to just getting notified when you
when you go uh yeah when you go live
whatever on youtube you're begging
everybody to ring the bell
and you're looking for it they're paying
five bucks a month to bring the belt
what game do you play just all of them
just anything that comes out
let me guess what this is like it's kind
of like yeah it's kind of like live
reviews now i'm all pc
so you getting any more bugattis i'm not
i'm
never gonna get a bugatti ever again in
my life um how often are you getting on
the twitch stream
every day no no like twice a month
oh my god maybe like a ufc
fighting game and get on twitch and like
yeah you gotta get on it man
if you got that many followers what if
we like collab on something
absolutely oh no i get oh yeah i do it
all the time
right i collab all the time and people
like make
twitch streams like the night that we
collab and they get
pretty much half of my [ __ ] followers
okay i i
love it so so towards there's a revenue
stream that's not music yeah that's
playing [ __ ] for
sure for big ass money it's it's
anything else
slipped your mind yeah
oh yeah by the way
the same [ __ ] as everybody man
cryptocurrency [ __ ]
cannabis [ __ ] it's just all it's sure
you're in the cannabis business
no i want to get in it but i i haven't
found
anything that's genuine enough it's it's
not
something that i actually [ __ ] with
enough
to where i can say hey guys i actually
like this
anything out anything you've seen me
come out with like you know any liquor
or
or cannabis or anything like that i have
to really like it first
all right i have to actually like it so
it won't be a such thing as you know the
company like well we're giving you money
so you got to do this
right you know what i'm saying it's
actually like me coming out like guys i
actually like this [ __ ]
so get it because i like it
i would drink it for free yeah i'm not
drinking it for free it's
[ __ ] yeah yeah but i gotta
like it i would have drank it if they
wouldn't have said anything
for example i wouldn't have taken this
product called blue chews blue blue
that's right blue chew tablets i
wouldn't i wouldn't have tried
what is that it's like it gets your [ __ ]
game up
it's uh it's it's got the same
ingredient as viagra and
cialis oh my god but it's chewable and
it's great fraction of the price
right now i would never have thought to
try that and you know they were like hey
man you want to try it i was like
[ __ ] dick pill all right i'll try it
and i'm like babe check out my boner
yeah you you know you noticed the
difference yeah i swear i did so i'm
ready
you know what i'm in let's let's all
right let's see if originally asked for
more than four hours
later yeah
yeah it's gotta be something that you
[ __ ] with man it's gotta be organic and
people can people can sense that [ __ ]
people can really see the consumers can
actually see if it's like
hey right try this thing i think for
sure people are so savvy for
authenticity
absolutely people are people learn that
[ __ ] because they because
it's the age of the influencer so now
literally anybody can just promote
anything you know what i'm saying so
it's everybody has their
everybody has a [ __ ] instagram
account everybody has their [ __ ]
everybody has a way
of you know putting products out there
and what's gonna make
your [ __ ] different what's gonna make
yours more authentic
it's because you actually [ __ ] like
it and you're not doing it for the money
and if you stop liking the [ __ ] and if
the company does some crazy [ __ ]
you can let it go it's not they don't
they don't have you held
for you know like we're going to stop
paying you if you don't
like okay
you know what i'm saying your life
doesn't depend on it you're all good you
don't have to [ __ ] depend on that
so it's just better when it's more
authentic it's kind of cool i think
about your music career a little bit
similarly because you sort of stuck to
like no this is what i do and a lot of
people
are like yo man maybe that's not the
coolest thing to do like yeah i like
this this is just what naturally comes
out of me so i'm going to keep doing it
and then it got to the point that's all
people wanted from you was just
bt pain and like and you were able to
just be successful
just by doing you absolutely yeah and
then that helps you
you know that helps out a lot dude i
mean it it frees you from a lot of [ __ ]
it it makes uh it makes you immune to
you know cutting people off makes you
immune to [ __ ] companies not [ __ ]
with you it makes you
immune to [ __ ] getting cancelled
like it's just like i didn't [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] in first place all right cool
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah cool it makes you immune to that it
makes you immune to
people it makes you immune to fake
[ __ ] that come in your circle
and they just try to
you know be around you because you have
certain things like
it it makes you immune to that when
you're authentic and when you
actually [ __ ] with something
it it gets you out of that space to be
[ __ ] with hell yeah all right i just
followed you on instagram man
there we go there we go t-pain that song
is just
t-pain on instagram it's it's so fast
that's not it's not complicated at all
it's not efficiency pain
pain it's not the reality pain
what else can we promote for you well
wait we gotta get this top five yeah
i want to hear the top five i'm dying to
know the top five the top five
um it's the normal top five it's the
[ __ ] j
cole kendrick lamar i don't know that
that's the normal top five this is very
normal
it's always the top two anybody else uh
well is this an order or not in order
it's not an
order uh this is the new school top five
kids lamar
oh this is all time or just right now no
no yeah
all the time michael jackson
um um um um
oh no quincy we're talking about rappers
i'll use that hip-hop and r b
ah okay now let's go rappers okay rap
yeah that's the scarier thing to
take rappers kendrick lamar um
corrupt um
corrupt young gotti
j cole
drake wow
um yeah well more uh
uh uh uh tech9 wow
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
you did your intro it's like on your
youtube channel like t-pain kills his
intro for his
channel that yeah oh my god that's
amazing the last one i did the last
because i have three different intros
the last one i did was inspired all by
tec-9
like that was my tech nine inch that was
like my homage to technology
what was the tune or the record the
track where you said they called me a
murderer
they called me a murder i just i
literally just heard this
[ __ ] somebody just posted this okay so
it doesn't matter
what uh the track is but why do they
call you a murderer
because because i was killing everybody
on their own songs oh
yeah killing everybody on their own song
anytime anytime you get t pain on your
song you just just
that's the t-pain song now it's steve
[Laughter]
it's like when you're a comedian you
bring a comic on the road to open for
you
and that guy's funnier than you and they
kill yeah that's murder
that is murder yeah yeah
but are you are they like this guy's
never coming on my album again right now
absolutely yeah really yeah yeah
i don't think you would want that yeah
i'll just want it all the time
i'm getting the time from an affirmation
for lobster
check out my only fans i'm just just me
jacking off all the time
check out everything uh t-pain on
craigslist i'm trying to sell a couch
twitch twitter twitch.tv
radio happy boy
i am terrible at promotion i'm not good
at that [ __ ]
uh just look for t just google t-pain
and see what comes up
all right get ready for uh the podcast
for sure right but we do yeah i'm
looking forward to that dude snappy boy
radio
coming very soon well let's hopefully
that lobster's out
[Laughter]
dude i love the [ __ ] setup in here
man how about that
dude come on man making music with
t-pain dude i mean we're gonna do it i
think
plus this guy i mean
he makes music man how do people get
their music
oh that kid is you on spotify
instagram and uh
elsewhere everywhere yeah and the [ __ ]
kicks ass
so [ __ ] check it out and let paul
briskey know that you did